foreign
this sense of the connection of our
Consciousness with a vastly greater
Consciousness is not a theory for people
who've had this experience it's an
experience
um I've had such experiences myself
um I'm a practicing Christian
um and one reason I am is that I've
actually had Direct experiences that
make the idea of a Consciousness beyond
our own not just a theory of proposition
in theology but an ex a natural
experience I've had which for me was
very convincing
now I know that
um atheists and materialists will say
well this is just uh the release of
dopamine in the brain or something like
that or Court circuiting various bits of
the brain
um and that it's all inside the head but
the fact is when you have these
experiences
um you're working on the basis of
experience I mean science is supposed to
be empirical which means experience this
is experience and to oppose it you don't
oppose it with materialist sounds with
experience you oppose it with ideology
the ideology that mind is nothing but
the brain
now I think that the limitations of that
ideology are very clear to anyone who's
had mystical experiences
um and increasing numbers of people are
having them partly because of the spread
of psychedelics which for many people
are a kind of rite of passage into a
larger view of Consciousness they
certainly were for me when I first took
psychedelics in 1971 or something like
that before that I was an atheist a
standard materialist atheists it went
with my scientific education and they
helped open my mind to new possibilities
and I later took up meditation and yoga
because I wanted to explore the realm of
Consciousness without drugs I mean not
against drugs but I'm not saying they're
necessary but for many people they're an
opening a a an opening to this realm of
experience
given that human beings have had these
experiences over Millennia given that
they underlie the enlightenment of the
Buddha it was a direct experience
Jesus's experience of his own closeness
to God was not as a result of doing a
PhD or going to a rabbinical Seminary it
was a direct experience
and these kinds of experiences are not
going to go away and for those who've
had them they're extremely meaningful
they're more meaningful than reading
books on popular science or people
trying to explain away near-death
experiences in terms of anoxia in the
brain and that kind of thing and I think
that they're likely therefore to lead to
a persistent
interest in spiritual practices and
these spiritual practices I'd likely to
lead to a Resurgence of connection with
religious traditions because if they're
just free-floating they're not rooted in
a tradition and they're not rooted in a
community and we religions provide many
things for people but they also they
provide a sense of interconnection in
community with other people in a way
that fragmented individualism doesn't
um so my own view is that it's very
likely that religions will evolve they
are evolving before our very eyes the
moment and that that many people will
find them of value my reply to that idea
that religions are based on an extra
intense deep no iron intended direct
experience but correct me if I'm wrong I
read some text by has already mentioned
it I think by so-called neuro theologies
who claim that and direct then theology
responses to them
neurotiologists claim that by doing
don't ask me what certain things to your
brain they can trigger something that
you experience precisely as this
intense religious experience and it's
interesting what is the theologist's
answer to them because here it seems
like a good proof you know nothing to do
with your inner life I do it to you in a
certain way okay and you will have that
type of experience but all the
experiences that you and I love your
presentations Rupert that you mentioned
you know like uh Buddha's Enlightenment
well I'm sorry
Buddha selectment for original Buddhism
itself was not in any sense a religious
experience it was simply an experience
of true nature of reality of the
ultimate void and so on and so on
Christian experience my God I'm
fascinated by it but for me and I agree
here with ultra theologists like my
beloved 20th century Gilbert kids Kester
Christ basic experience is that father
father why have you abandoned me which
is precisely an incredible intense
experience of the separation from God
which is the way I see it unique I can
argue about this later unique for
Christianity so I would nonetheless go a
little bit further in this direction
that our Earth
our religious experience no matter how
intensely personal is it is it's
historically forum
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV